Angola una potencia del Oro negro la
antigua Colonia portuguesa produce un
millón 200.000 barriles de petróleo al
día el recurso representa el 40% de su
producto interior bruto mientras que los
hidrocarburos suponen el 90% de sus
exportaciones una operación que lleva a
cabo la petrolera local son angol pero
también las grandes occidentales como
total Energy presente en el país desde
1953 la empresa francesa emplea allí
unas 1100 personas y construye
plataformas petroleras pero también
infraestructura de producción de energía
renovable ahora Emmanuel macron está de
viaje en Angola el jefe de estado
francés quiere poner su visita bajo el
signo de la diversificación económica
Francia pretende ayudar a Angola a
conquistar su soberanía alimentaria
luanda depende de sus importaciones de
alimentos básicos a pesar de los
importantes recursos
hídricos y un clima favorable para la
agricultura el país explota solo 5,9
millones de hectáreas de su tierra
cultivable cuando son 35 millones los
que tiene disponibles Angola espera
atraer inversores franceses para
explotar este potencial una ardua tarea
para un país no francófono con un clima
de negocios difícil